what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and we
made it another
week the falcon and the winter soldier
episode 4 is happening tonight
at midnight and it looks like some
pretty interesting and
brutal things are about to go down in
episode four in fact i think we might
see the death of a certain character in
episode four so if you're trying to
avoid any and all spoilers for episode
four
in case i get it right this is your
spoiler warning now we do have some
photos of episode 4 and a leaked
video showing us what probably is going
to happen throughout this episode so my
assumption of what's going to happen is
based off of
actual footage so you've been warned if
you're still with me i'll be talking
about the new captain america at least
for the moment
john walker how i think sam might get
the shield back from
john walker baron zemo of course and
possibly some very big surprises coming
from emily van camp's character
sharon carter we have definitely not
seen the last of her
yet last week i actually put out a
theory stating that i believe that she
could be the power broker and
she recently in an interview addressed
this theory so
a lot to go over today but don't forget
about my captain america shield giveaway
just follow me and follow my other
channel cosmic culture
details in the description down below so
we'll start off with this picture from a
scene
of episode 4 that we're going to be
getting tonight tomorrow
as you can see here this picture is of
john walker on his knees
with his head down leaning on the shield
he looks
very very defeated and if you notice on
the left side of that shield there is a
ton of blood on it now before we get
into that let's look at the background
because it actually looks like the
background of the warehouse in episode
2.
specifically the warehouse where the
flag smashers were taking some medicine
from the grc
the same warehouse that sam and bucky
were hiding in before they attacked them
this looks like john walker is still
tracking down the flax masters and he
tracks them down to
possibly another grc warehouse there he
could get into an altercation with them
and could have been not so nice or
merciful with them
as we can kind of tell by the blood on
the shield now in the second episode of
the falcon and the winter soldier we
were introduced to john walker before he
went out for his parade and his good
morning america interview
and when he was in the locker room his
wife was there and also battlestar was
there as well
and battlestar specifically told him
that he can't just punch his way out of
things
anymore giving us a hint that john
walker isn't really that much of a
peacekeeper but more of a shoot first
and ask questions later type of guy
and in the comics john walker is
actually known for being a more
brutal captain america he doesn't have
the same morals and ethics as steve
rogers which nobody really does
that's why everybody loves steve so much
and it looks like we're going to see
that brutality come out based off of
this blood on the shield but something
to notice
about this picture is that battle star
is not
anywhere to be seen john walker appears
to be alone which doesn't really make
sense the fighting is seemingly over
john walker is sitting on his knees it
seems like he's resting
and again it seems like he's defeated
after a battle it would make sense that
hoskins would be right next to walker
but he's not
and it appears that john walker just
went kind of crazy
could the death of battle star be why
john walker goes crazy and starts
bashing people's heads in with the
shield
i believe this to be the case because if
you take this photo and you actually
combine it with a leaked video that we
got several several months ago for the
falcon and the winter soldier of john
walker
it makes sense because this leaked video
shows john walker completely
losing it and bashing somebody's skull
in possibly decapitating
them with the shield and as he's beating
this person's face and with the shield
you can actually hear him yelling
look at me
let's take a look at that one more time
in case you didn't see it or hear what
he's saying
now john walker is clearly in a rage
here and i think the death of battlestar
is probably what put him in that rage
because we don't see him in this video
either
if we think back to the second episode
of the falcon and the winter soldier
where they were fighting on top of the
trucks battle star didn't really hold
the zone that well
and john walker didn't really either but
considering the fact that they're facing
off against super soldiers it makes
sense
of course they're not going to be able
to take on a handful of super soldiers
and this actually makes me think of a
rather dark thought but i think the
blood on the shield
might actually be battlestar's blood
because in that same episode in that
same scene we can actually see john
walker throw his shield and hit some of
the flag smashers in the head
and as we saw it did absolutely nothing
it looked like it just kind of irritated
them a little bit but it didn't take off
their head or break their skin or cause
them to bleed or anything like that
so the blood on the shield probably is
not from one of the flax smashers i
sadly think it's going to be from
hoskins aka battle star
now from here i believe that john walker
is going to try and take a super soldier
serum whose serum could that be
i'm not sure it could be the us
government it could be perhaps a serum
from the power broker
after all he is tracking down the flag
smashers he could run into some serum
since they stole it
and i think him getting the super
soldier serum is kind of going to make
him go
power crazy and seek revenge on the flax
masters which is when i think we're
going to get this scene
of him bashing a flax master's face in
or possibly decapitating them and i
think the reason he's saying look at me
is because they killed his friend now
ultimately i think sam and bucky are
going to find out about this and i think
they're going to confront him about it
and i believe that this is when sam is
going to get the shield back
we've seen plenty of previews with sam
actually holding the shield and using
the shield so we know he's going to get
it back at some point in time but we've
seen
a lot of footage with him using it and
there's only three episodes left
so it has to happen relatively soon so i
think after john walker essentially
abuses the power of captain america or
gives him a bad look
he will either willingly give it up to
sam or sam and bucky will take it after
all bucky has been talking about taking
the shield from john walker because in
that video a lot of people
are filming so the internet and of
course the world is going to see this
new captain america who is supposed to
be a beacon of hope
brutally murder somebody which is
obviously bad so one way or another
this is going to result in sam getting
the shield and i think we'll probably
see that during the middle or the
end of the next episode episode 4. so
this could be a very brutal episode but
i also think we're going to get a little
bit more information
about emily van camp's sharon carter her
character is definitely not done whether
she appears in this episode or some
future episodes
and as i mentioned she was actually
asked in a recent interview about the
theory of her
being the power broker herself in which
she responded
we could interpret that in so many
different ways there's still three
episodes left so hopefully those
questions will be answered
there's still lots of characters to come
in and out
the problem could be many things this
definitely leads me to believe that she
is involved with the power broker in
some way shape or form
especially based off of her response
when they asked her in the interview
what did she mean when she told her
bodyguard they've got a problem
actually a couple in which she responded
i don't want
to say what but obviously there are so
many things
it doesn't seem like sam bucky and zemo
tracking down the flag smashers and
trying to kill the new super soldier
program could be a problem for sharon
carter unless she's involved somehow
she's clearly doing very well in
magiport and she's over in the high town
end
and it seems like she's very very
connected and in the interview when she
was asked about the ethics and morals
that sharon used to have
she said i think she's left a lot of
that behind she's probably had to make
some very difficult decisions and do
some things she didn't want to do
this could definitely mean that she is
associating herself with some characters
that she really wouldn't want to
but given the fact that she had to run
to magipore just to survive
you kind of do what you have to do and
again i want to reiterate i don't think
sharon is bad i think she just had to
make some tough choices
but hopefully by the end of this she can
return to the states if
zemo doesn't get in the way a lot of
people think that zemo of course
is still bad and is going to stab sam
and bucky in the back somehow
which let's be honest is probably going
to happen in some way shape or form even
though i do
have some hope that he is kind of good
however when daniel bruhl who of course
plays zema was asked in a recent
interview
if anyone could trust zemo he said no
never so we'll have to wait and see zemo
clearly has his own plans and is not
just going along with bucky and sam for
no reason so hopefully that will get
revealed a little bit more
in this next episode but let me know
what you think about john walker's
captain america possibly going crazy and
going on
a killing rampage because of the
possible death of battlestar and let me
know if you think sharon carter could be
the power broker or could be
working for the power broker don't
forget to subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all
marvel news don't forget to like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter and
the giveaway details are in the
description down below
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof